[Musique]
moi général de gaulle j'en prends ici en
angleterre
cette teinte nationale souvenons-nous en
adolf hitler et les nazis de l'alva y
décide de déclarer la guerre à la france
ils envahissent france enfin d'après le
tissu juin 1940 le général de gaulle
lance un appel au peuple de france à
tout le peuple de france a résisté à ne
pas céder à la panique
et puis la france organise le 28
novembre 1940 de l'appel du général de
gaulle qui a été entendue à la réunion
fait qu'ici sur cette place où nous
sommes
le léopard arrive au large des côtes de
la réunion pour inviter les jeunes
réunionnais qui veulent aller se battre
à côté des forces françaises libres du
général de gaulle de monter à boé de
rejoindre blanche est ici même là là où
cette place cette statue a été érigée et
bien il y avait des de nombreux jeunes
dont certains n'avaient pas 18 ans qui
était du volontaire pour aller combattre
c'était le 28 novembre 1942 et le 8 mai
1945 la france a vaincu l'allemagne
l'allemagne défaite
l'allemagne est battu la france du
général de gaulle a gagné nous sommes le
8 mai 1945 au mois d'octobre 1945 le
gouvernement français décide de l'ancien
des élections pour élire des députés qui
constitueront l'assemblée constituante
de la france
les deux députés qui sont élus les ont
des pervenches raymond vergès rejoindre
mois paris leurs homologues aimé césaire
et d autre député de la martinique de la
guadeloupe de la guyane
ils obtiennent que le 19 mars 1946 soit
votée la loi qui fait de notre pays un
département français
si le général de gaulle n'avait pas
lancé son appel aujourd'hui peut-être
soyons nous toujours
une colonne plus tard l'europe viendra
et nous serons à la réunion la région
ultrapériphérique de l'europe la région
française de l'europe ultra périphérique
dans l'océan indien
aujourd'hui nous avons à poursuivre le
travail qui a été fait par les autres eh
bien je me félicite que des jeunes dans
ce pays
sentent leurs responsabilités et je
voudrais citer cette jeune fille qui a
14 ans seulement et qui déclarait dans
la presse cette semaine
j'ai conscience aujourd'hui que nous
vivons une période très difficile et en
tant que jeune réunionnaise
je ne sais pas très bien à quoi
ressemblera notre avenir mais je sais je
me dis qu'il faut qu'on garde espoir il
y aura des jours meilleurs
et bien grâce général de gaulle à son
engagement
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec nos jeunes
dans une période nous allons le bac pour
améliorer les choses c'est de cela que
nous allons discuter dans quelques
instants
[Musique]